[Música]
hola que tal bienvenidos a la entrevista
de france 24 se acerca el tour de
francia y en la baraja de favoritos se
empieza a aparecer el nombre de un
ciclista colombiano tiene 26 años es de
soacha en las cercanías de bogotá y
después de haber sido sobre todo un
gregario de lujo para sus compañeros
ahora demuestra como un líder capaz de
medirse de tú a tú con los mejores
pedalistas del mundo daniel felipe
martínez bienvenido
muchísimas gracias por la invitación
para luego especial para ustedes y todos
los televidentes
banias tenido un comienzo de temporada
admirable podemos decir campeón de la
historia de la vuelta al país vasco
tercero en la parís niza cuarto en la
lieja bastoña lieja y quinto en la
flecha valona sientes que estás en el
mejor nivel de tu carrera profesional
sí sin duda este año es un año bastante
bueno para mí
digamos que
ha sido el mejor año que he tenido en mi
carrera deportiva
este año hablando lexuri es una carrera
bastante importante a nivel en el
calendario y ahora tratándose de los
objetivos nuevos
danny ahora sonríes pero el año pasado
no fue tan bueno que djokovic y te
perdiste de los juegos olímpicos de
tokio como fue terminar ese 2021 y
encarar la preparación para esta
temporada actual
si el año pasado tenía un objetivo muy
marcado que era después del giro de
italia en los juegos olímpicos
lastimosamente acabé de unitaria con
kobe y ver realmente muy difícil
recuperar me dure casi dos meses dando
positivo en los en los pc eres y bueno
entonces puede ir a los juegos olímpico
sport por esto y digamos que las
acciones no eran buenas y que
prácticamente que dimos por terminada la
temporada después del giro de italia
pero bueno este año iniciamos muy bien
descansamos bastante
bien el año pasado y ya no vamos con
ganas están en esas pequeñas cosas la
clave de estar en un equipo como el ine
es que te digan que prácticamente a
mitad del año pasado terminó tu
temporada para encarar la otra como es
ese momento en que el equipo te dice eso
y como lo preparas tú sabiendo que aún
quedaban bastante meses desde 2021
es difícil porque
realmente terminemos bien el giro de
italia el equipo al que éste haya
terminado muy bien el italiano había
programado
lo iba a aumentar con más empresas al
día estaba muy motivado pero corre
selectivamente ocho días después
mira kobe y sigo dando positiva entonces
fue bastante frustrante porque tenía
marcado como siguiente objetivo la
vuelta españa y terminar una temporada
si tan pronto digamos que no es la mejor
forma pero bueno lo importante era
recuperar bien darle al cuerpo el
descanso necesario y creo que lo hicimos
con el equipo bastante bien
en la historia ya mostraste que puedes
ganar a primos arreglista y además vimos
que tus compañeros garín tomás y hagan
jets no tienen problemas en trabajar
para ti cómo te has sentido al ser el
líder de un equipo tan poderoso como el
ine os
es una responsabilidad bastante grande
cuando un equipo consigue estar
realmente muy buenos
te dice que te van a dar la batuta del
equipo así que con mucha responsabilidad
pero muy tranquilo realmente
digamos que estoy en un equipo donde
sabe trabajar donde son donde le
diseñara uno así que digamos que me
gusta estar en este equipo porque saben
trabajar muy bien y dar la confianza a
uno lo más importante
ya con el education first ganaste un
criterium pero esa presión de ser líder
de la que nos hablas es mayor cuando
está haciendo líneas en un equipo
británico y compartiendo equipo con
británicos
sí sí sí sin duda el equipo es que
realmente muy
mucha responsabilidad ver que un campeón
del tour de francia está trabajando
tirando del grupo para ti y otros
compañeros realmente que tienen mucha
clase sanz ayudándote así que digamos
que esto te da un plus de más en las
carreras la pregunta que todos nos
hacemos vas a ser el líder de líneas
para el tour de francia
bueno de momento el líder para entonces
francia sigue siendo balance grades el
digamos que desde el año pasado he
su objetivo en la competencia
yo digamos que voy de de segundo
allí en el equipo miraremos como cómo
jugamos nuestras fichas y también
esperan a ver cómo llega granito más a
la carrera sin dudas una ciclista se
conoce muy bien esta competencia y desde
mucha experiencia allí que digamos que
las tres cartas de oración
a ti particularmente de aquí a que
llegue el tour de francia te gustaría
ser el líder el más fuerte de líneas
para el tour de francia
si de momento estoy preparando bien
centrando bastante bien aquí en colombia
y ahora más o menos en unos 10 días
viajo para
europa afrontar el tour de suiza y ahí
miraremos como como vamos de cara al
tour pero la carrera de poner cada quien
en su sitio ya miraremos
si es demuestra bastante superioridad
sin duda le ayudaré no tengo un problema
en eso y bueno estoy
bueno yo creo que el equipo
y va a ayudar
y como este sentido en estas semanas de
entrenamiento en este momento clave de
la temporada justo antes del tour como
son las sensaciones
bien entrenado bastante fuerte las
sensaciones son buenas
decir me encuentro realmente muy bien y
bueno un motivado de cara a lo que se
viene
qué te parece el recorrido de este tour
de francia' te gusta
es un recorrido bastante exigente la
primer semana como todas las de tour de
francia más de una semana digamos que
con mucho estrés porque iniciamos en
dinamarca
y ya después y me llamo al norte de
clase que sabemos que había mucho viento
van a ser etapas aunque piernas del meta
paipa mente la stream o reconocían lo
hice una etapa muy dura hay que estar
una pista previamente adelante
y contarles elegía con
encima ayuda bastante porque es una
etapa que sí día de sol es una bici 9 es
otra completamente diferente así que
el recorrido es bastante exigente y ya
la etapa de montaña en los alpes y los
pirineos es muy exigente realmente hay
dos etapas de contrarreloj una de 13
otra de 45 llegadas en alto con este
perfil crees tú que tú puedes rivalizar
plantarle cara de tú a tú hasta de paul
achar primero glitch
si llego en altura y no encuentro como
lo venía haciendo
en meses anteriores yo creo que sí yo
creo que
la superioridad de primos y épocas
también en las contrarrelojs es obvia
trataré de buscar ventaja en la montaña
y aprovechar el equipo que tengo un
equipo bastante fuerte para los
adoquines y los vientos de costado así
que trataremos de aprovechar día a día y
dar la oportunidad donde podemos sacarle
tiempo a ellos
vamos a dejar de hablar del tour de
francia tú y otros tantos ciclistas como
gun bernal nairo quintana d'arrigo y
varios más hace parte de una generación
dorada del ciclismo colombiano pero en
este país en colombia hay un problema de
dopaje colombia es junto con costa rica
la nación con más accionados por dopaje
en el mundo como se explican tantos
positivos
es lamentable realmente que esto es muy
lamentable
venimos donde quizás estamos en europa
ánimo hay un trabajo espectacular día a
día pero sin duda digamos que seguimos
latinoamérica no tiene todavía un chip
muy antiguo no
realmente que esto no debería ocurrir en
ningún deporte y es lamentable como te
digo yo creo que hace falta más
conciencia
en latinoamérica hace cuanto más
controles antidopaje para que realmente
este flagelo no va más
particularmente en el caso de colombia
nosotros hemos hablado con algunos
ciclistas y nos dicen que aquí fuera de
los campeonatos nacionales y la vuelta a
colombia los controles no llegan a ser
tan exigentes desde tu experiencia cuál
crees que es el panorama
es difícil yo creo que como te digo eso
es falta de conciencia de los mismos
ciclistas de los equipos aquí en
colombia porque sabemos que colombia es
una cuna de cristal a nivel mundial y
este es un flagelo que no se debería
estar viviendo realmente porque ahora
están los ciclistas muy jóvenes para
europa y realmente quedan muchos los que
quedan digamos que
se metan en este mundo y todo el dopaje
es realmente muy duro así que hace falta
más controles estrictos por parte de la
uci y también de la federación y de las
federaciones de cada país en inglés y en
américa para que realmente esto se
controle mucho más no digamos a
comparación de europa que es toda
[Música]
aquí en la
que también sería bueno que
los gobiernos es consciente y saben más
de esto y entrenar realmente más duras
precisamente este problema afecta sobre
todo a los jóvenes hay recambio en
colombia para esta generación dorada de
la que estamos viendo en este momento
sí y sin duda aquí hay una escuela
bastante grande hay unos hay una cantera
bastante fuerte y ahora el ciclismo es
un deporte de moda aquí colombiano
entonces hay mucha chico motivado y creo
que era serbia así que yo creo que van a
estar saliendo ciclistas cada vez más
para terminar me decías antes que estás
cómodo en el ineos pero hay rumores de
que puedes cambiar de equipo para el
próximo año vas a seguir en el línea
normalmente tengo otro año más de
contrato con el equipo con el equipo y
de ahí para allá vamos a mirar realmente
me siento muy contento muy a gusto
trabajando con ellos
y miraremos miraremos de cara al futuro
pero lo que te puedo decir es que para
próximo año es igual
donde felipe martínez te deseamos lo
mejor para lo que resta de temporada y
sobre todo para ese tour de francia'
muchas gracias
muchas gracias y a ustedes también
muchas gracias como siempre por estar en
la pantalla de france 24 que desde
porque la información continúa aquí y
también en france 24 punto com
[Música]